travis scott isn't taking any chances
stopping his show due to safety concerns
the rapper performed an impromptu set at
the coney island art walls independence
day event in new york
[Music]
the show was packed crowds clamoring to
check out travis's performance and at
one point a few fans climbed up the
metal lighting truss to get a better
view that's when travis abruptly stopped
the show
[Music]
a rep for travis tells e.t he's quote
committed to doing his part to ensure
events are as safe as possible so that
fans can have fun he encouraged fans to
listen to requests from security and
climb down from the lighting structures
so that everyone would be able to safely
enjoy that night's performance this
comes just days after travis was set to
headline the day in vegas festival his
first major performance since the
tragedy at his astroworld festival in
november where 10 people died and
hundreds were injured due to extreme
crowding i'm honestly just devastated
and
i could never imagine anything like this
just
happening you know my fans my fans like
my fans really mean the world to me and
i always just really want to leave them
with a positive experience travis is
still facing major repercussions and
billions of dollars in lawsuits
as for the day in vegas festival it was
ultimately scrapped due to a combination
of logistics timing and production
issues
[Music]
travis's first big solo show since the
tragedy is scheduled in early august at
the o2 arena in london
[Music]
you